cheeri committees top Democrat that
Senator Dianne Feinstein says not
interviewing bread Cavanaugh or
Christine Blasi Ford quote raises
serious concerns that this is not a
credible investigation and begs the
question what are the restrictions as a
white house placed on the FBI jeffrey
gazes outside FBI headquarters in
Washington Jeff good morning to you do
you think the bureau is satisfied with
its report today
good morning FBI officials knew that
this case would put them right in the
middle of a political firestorm and
that's exactly where they are six days
after this supplemental background
investigation began this was not a
criminal probe where the FBI could just
follow leads wherever they may go in
this case the White House set the
parameters on who to interview and what
to look into so dr. Ford was not
interviewed nor was Judge Cavanaugh FBI
agents relied on their public testimony
from last week's hearing to track down
witnesses ultimately about seven people
were interviewed as the FBI tried to
corroborate the allegations once the
probe was completed summaries of those
interviews were turned over the White
House in a background inquiry like this
the FBI does not come to conclusions
that's up to the White House and this
morning The Wall Street Journal is
reporting that the White House found no
support for the allegations but we're
just gonna have to see what the senators
think when they get that report aura
that is the key question Jeff thank you